[Music]
today we are here with Harshit who is a
senior ml engineer with quantify and we
are super excited to learn about some of
the machine learning solutions built by
quantify before we get started can you
tell us a bit more about quantifying
sure so we are an AI ml company at our
core and we provide end-to-end data as
well as ml solutions for our customers
we've been around for over six years and
we have offices in the United States
Canada and India we are also a Google
cloud certified partner and we have been
awarded the Google ml partner of the
Year for 2017 and 2018 awesome can you
talk more about what it means to be a
Google cloud partner
sure so we've been a Google cloud
partner for about four years now and we
have over 325 employees who are you
without certified professionals so what
this partnership means to us is that we
are often at the forefront of newest GCP
tools and technologies available we get
to be in contact with the product
development team doing in order to
provide solutions to our customers and
also we're able to provide feedback back
to the product development team so that
they can better design new your features
great tell us about cue Docs
sure so cue Docs is an enterprise-grade
productized document processing solution
so it's designed to handle oppressive
workloads of converting documents into
useable data so it uses a combination of
traditional
OCR and custom deep learning models for
handling virtually any template of
documents and to convert into a
knowledge base which can be leveraged
for any further business uses we have a
ton of features available in cue Docs so
for example entity recognition key value
pairing digitizing unstructured in
structured tables digitizing charts
graphs maps and so on and also under the
hood we have an active learning pipeline
which ensures continuous improvement of
our ml models so any feedback the use of
Weitz helps us in improving our own
email models as well can you talk about
some of the specific technologies that
were used when you were building to Docs
absolutely in order to keep our design
as scalable and customizable as possible
we used a lot of GCP tools for building
a solution from the start to the end
basically the user has the option of
uploading their documents to Google
Cloud wire multiple sources like UI or
emails or simple drag-and-drop now all
of these documents are stored in Google
Cloud storage as a staging area which
triggers a cloud task which sends out
asynchronous triggers to App Engine for
processing these documents so we use
vision API for converting this image and
document into text and we also have
custom ml models which are containerized
and stored in App Engine for handling
all of the ML tasks now the results can
be stored in various data storages so if
you want relational database you can use
for example bigquery or cloud sequel or
if you want a no sequel database you can
use BigTable of fire store and if you
also want any visualization or Business
Analytics you can port these results to
any analytics tool of your choice a
looker or tableau or data studio what
are some of the challenges that you
encountered when building code arcs we
designed cue docks with an evolutionary
architecture so that it's capable of
recognizing any challenges and adapting
to it in the future so some of the
challenges we faced were firstly we had
data shortage issue so we realized that
if we need to provide high standards of
accuracy we might not be able to cover
all templates so if user feedback is
very important in that scenario so we
included the active learning pipeline so
anytime a user provides feedback for a
particular document that document
becomes the data point which helps in
retraining our models and ensuring that
the accuracy level keeps on increasing
secondly another challenge which we
faced was that earlier we had used cloud
functions for deploying our ml models
but we found out that our ml models were
too computationally heavy and we would
often face a time out
functions so instead we used app engine
which integrates well with cloud tasks
and it's also able to scale up and
Leslie for our ml models as well great
well Harsha thank you so much for being
here with us today and for sharing more
about cue Docs thank you for having this
if you'd like to learn more about
quantify you can visit quantify calm
thanks for watching and stay tuned for
more episodes of stack chat
[Music]
you